[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
aurélien pradié bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous député du lot
secrétaire général des républicains en
détention pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est bonjour stéphane
bonjour stéphane qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
on commence par françois fillon françois
fillon condamné à cinq ans de prison
dont deux ferme et une peine
d'inéligibilité de dix ans pour
détournement de fonds publics que pensez
vous de ce jugement rien prédire
je commande pas la décision de justice
je tâche de ne jamais le faire et je ne
le ferai pas sur cette situation là je
pense qu'il faut tourner la page pour
françois fillon pour les français pour
notre famille politique il est temps de
tourner la page les décisions de justice
a été rendue je crois qu'on appelle a
été a été demandée mais pas de
commentaires hier bruno retailleau qui
était sur notre plateau disait que c'est
une peine extrêmement sévère c'est vos
billets mais je n'ai pas à commenter une
décision de justice vraiment c'est une
discipline à laquelle je me tiens à la
fois pour mes amis politiques tout comme
mes ennemis politiques et pour n'importe
quel concitoyens je pense simplement
qu'il est temps de tourner la page
y compris pour françois fillon lui-même
alors vous commentez pas mais les
avocats de françois fillon avait demandé
la réouverture des débats après les
révélations des lianes houlette du
parquet national financier qui avait
parlé de pression à son encontre ça vous
pouvez vous pouvez vous pouvez commenter
ça ou pas il ya deux sujets différents
il ya la question de la faire françois
fillon elle a été placée devant la
justice la justice a rendu sa décision
et je n'ai pas en respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs à le commenter
l'autre question qui se pose depuis
plusieurs semaines et plusieurs mois
dans notre pays c'est l'indépendance de
la justice et la manière dont nos
magistrats ce qu'ils sont censés faire
respecter la loi et sanctionner
lorsqu'elle n'est pas respecté le font
ou ne le font pas en toute indépendance
indépendance de la justice où
débarquaient sait pas exactement la même
chose mais le sujet est globale vous le
voyez bien il va largement au delà des
parcs et d'ailleurs je pense que
lorsqu'on s'arc boute sur la question
l'indépendance du parquet c'est pour
éviter traiter la question de
l'institution judiciaire dans son
ensemble il n'y a pas d'indépendance de
la justice en france non je pense qu'on
a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui sur
l'indépendance de la justice et je vais
vous dire même plus je pense qu'on a un
vrai sujet sur la caste de la justice ce
qui tue la démocratie ce sont les effets
de castres c'est vrai en politique c'est
vrai dans la justice est vrai en
économie c'est vrai dans tous les
domaines d'organisation notre société et
je ne suis pas certain aujourd'hui que
la justice de notre pays ne soit pas
organisé comme une casse
elle s'apprend quelle forme cet effet de
caste au sénat justice croyais juste
nous presse donnée de 3 précise ça il
faudrait changer pour comme ça peut être
le 40 politique c'est l'effet d'entre
eux soit les phenom puneet aient le
sentiment qu'on ne rend de comptes à
personne le sentiment qu'on est au livre
dessus de tous de toute chose au dessus
du peuple ça arrive aussi en politique
ça peut aussi parfaitement arrivé avec
les magistrats
donc je pense qu'on a un vrai travail à
faire sur le renouvellement du personnel
de la magistrature sur leur formation
sûrement et aussi sur la manière dont
les politiques cessent d'intervenir dans
les affaires de justice
la création du parc national financiers
on a été la démonstration
c'était un outil politique on en a
aujourd'hui quasiment la conviction de
tiges de dépose une proposition là
justement pour supprimer ces parquet
national financier vous êtes d'accord il
a sûrement raison il faut le supprimer
mais ça ne suffira pas à reposer les
bases de la justice dans notre pays
enfin écoutez je pourrais ne pas vous
dire tout ce que je vous dis là mais la
vérité c'est qu'il n'y a pas seulement
les politiques qui ont une défiance à
l'égard de la justice et aussi nos
concitoyens tous les jours je rencontre
des françaises et des français qui ne
croient plus en leur justice
alors on peut considérer que ces
français là n'ont rien compris à la
justice que sont des citoyens qu'on ne
doit pas écouter
sauf que dans une nation dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre quand il y à
une telle rupture entre la justice les
citoyens et ce qui représente les
citoyens c'est qu'il ya un véritable
problème
donc vaut clairement aujourd'hui vous ne
fait plus confiance à la justice si je
fais confiance à la justice de mon pays
sans ça je serais pas député de la
nation
je dis simplement que faire confiance et
aussi être exigeant et je pourrais ne
pas tenir le discours un peu dur que je
tiens à l'instant si je ne le faisais
pas je serai pas la hauteur de mes
responsabilités on va passer à l'autre
actualité l'autre actualité c'est cette
mobilisation des soignants aujourd'hui
mobilisation de l'hôpital
à quelques jours de la fin du ségur de
la santé olivier ferrand qui a déjà mis
6 milliards sur la table qui a dit hier
qu'il proposait une rallonge de 300
millions d'euros pour les médecins est
ce que vous dites que le gouvernement
fait ce qu'il faut je pense que tout ça
c'est du bricolage
alors oui 10 milliards à ces messies
milliards c'est beaucoup mais on peut
avoir ce débat a été un élément c'est
évidemment pas suffisant si on veut
refonder totalement notre système de
santé
il faut il faut il faut placer la barre
à 7 milliards reçus de 14 milliards vous
la mettez vous l'avez la barre
ni et phonie sud donc je sais pas c'est
quoi les bons moyens pour le pied ça
passionnant les moyens c'est qu'est ce
que l'on veut faire de l'hôpital public
et de l'hôpital privé demain comment
est-ce qu'on revoie la totalité des
salaires de celles et ceux qui
travaillent dans l'hôpital comment on
les refonde profondément pas seulement
un grand coup de primes qui sont
éphémères comment est ce qu'on fait en
sorte qu'aujourd'hui dans nos hôpitaux
de proximité on puisse avoir des soins
qui ont disparu depuis plusieurs mois et
plusieurs années
si la question était seulement une
question financière on aurait pu la
règle est déjà depuis plusieurs mois ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il faudra des
moyens considérables et que même si
milliards ça ne suffit pas si on veut
refonder tout l'outil mais il faut avoir
le courage d'aller plus loin aussi
merkel suite à une rechute
organisationnel évidemment et ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que d'aligner
des milliards prétendument parce que
j'ai toujours pas compris pour les 6
milliards qui ont été annoncés sur
combien d'années il allait être
débloquée on n'a toujours pas cette
explication 6 milliards sur un an et 6
milliards sur dix ans c'est pas tout à
fait la même histoire
l'autre actualité c'est agnès buzyn
agnès buzyn l'ancienne miss de la santé
qui est devant les députés
cet après midi devant la commission
parlementaire chargée de faire la
lumière sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire qu'est ce que vous attendez de
l'audition d'agnès besoin de comprendre
de comprendre pas d'accuser mais de
comprendre ce qui a pu se passer
d'abord il était temps la situation
d'agnès buzyn à mon sens c est un des
exemples des plus grands naufrages
politique depuis plusieurs années je
vous rappelle qu'elle était quasi une
madone en macro ni il ya encore quelques
mois
voyez où elle a atterri politiquement
aujourd'hui et je pense que ce que nous
avons du mal les uns les autres à lui
pardonner ou à lui excusé c'est le fait
que l ai refusé d'assumer ses
responsabilités une fois qu'elle avait
quitté le navire
pascal aka même quitté le navire est
quand même parti mener une campagne
désastreuse à paris pour s'épargner
d'avoir à gérer une crise sanitaire
aussi lourde que celle qu'elle est que
nous avons pu connaître dont j'attends
des explications
y compris sur la question des masques et
surtout sur les alertes qu'elle a
prétendument lancé et qui n'auraient pas
été entendu
j'espère qu'on aura ces détails là
aujourd'hui pensez vraiment qu'elle a
fait acte de candidature à paris pour
ses parades pour s'épargner d'avoir à
gérer la crise où on a peut-être poussé
un peu à partir aussi non écoutez quand
on est responsable politique quand on
est mis sur la santé oms n'ai jamais
poussé et si on est trop poussé on se
retient
lorsqu'on est ministre la santé qu'on
lance des alertes qu'on a comme elle
prétend le dire conscience de la
situation extrêmement grave qui attend
le pays
on se barre pas désolé de le dire comme
je le pense mais on ne part pas faire
une kamba lectorale si on est convaincu
que la santé de nos concitoyens qui lie
à une crise sanitaire lourde à laquelle
il faudra faire face ça s'appelle le
sens des responsabilités dont qu'elle a
une responsabilité dans la gestion
elle a une responsabilité politique pour
le reste c'est à la commission denquête
de le dire moi je juge en politique ou
plutôt je donne un avis politique et mon
avis politique c'est qu'elle n'a pas été
la hauteur de ses responsabilités vous
disiez vous aviez la volonté de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé sur
lesquelles quel point particulier
aujourd'hui pour vous re est parti tout
à fait qu'ils restent à éclaircir
celui des alertes à nice buzaré prétend
que elle a alerté le président de la
république le premier ministre très tôt
qu'est ce qui fait que ces alertes là
n'ont pas été entendus qu'est ce qui
fait que il a fallu plusieurs mois avant
que de véritables décisions sanitaires
soient prises c'est ça qui m'intéresse
qui mène ses rêves provoqué du retard à
l'allumage dans l'année suivante mais ça
m'intéresse pas seulement pour pointer
tel ou tel responsable politique je
redis que s'il faut la pointer tous les
points seront parce que la politique
c'est assumé ses responsabilités quand
on commet une faute aussi grave en
politique on doit assumer et en payer
les conséquences
mais c'est aussi pour comprendre comment
dans une machinerie d'état comme la
france peut peut la voir
on lance une alerte une ministre la
santé lance une alerte et ça ne réagit
pas ça c'est absolument stupéfiant est
extrêmement préoccupant emmanuel macron
a réuni hier les 150 membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat il a
fait un discours il a annoncé un
calendrier il a annoncé un cap sur cette
écologie est ce que vous avez senti un
tournant écologique sur le président
hier au moins les tournages et emmanuel
macron je lis en assez peu ils sont
tellement répété que j'ai un peu de mal
à y croire mais il y adeux ceux de sujet
qui m'interroge d'abord celui de la
convention citoyenne je pense qu'ils
manuel macron s'amuse avec la convention
citoyenne et je le dis là aussi comme je
le pense pour lui c'est un gadget c'est
une jauge aux politiques ce qui m est
invraisemblable que il se présente
devant la convention citoyenne lendemain
des élections municipales à côté la
ficelle est quand même un peu grosse
pour octobre comme de la stratégie
politique pour emmanuel macron c'est
d'un cynisme consommer en revanche je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'on
doit regarder cette convention citoyenne
tas pour la calquer parce que moi je
crois en la démocratie représentative je
pense que des élus la nation qui sommes
d'abord des citoyens
nous avons un rôle d'intermédiation
d'intermédiaire
faire dans l'expression la démocratie et
de l'intérêt général
mais pour autant nous sommes à un moment
où nos concitoyens ont besoin de mieux
être impliqué dans la vie de leur
démocratie c'est ce qui se passe dans
beaucoup de villes de droite d'ailleurs
beaucoup de maires de droite ont mis en
place des outils qu'on appelle de
démocratie participative et je ne fais
pas partie de ceux qui balaient d'un
revers de la main cet outil là je pense
qu'il faut que nous y travaillons et je
pense que les républicains la droite
républicaine doit faire des propositions
pour rénover nos institutions sur cette
grande base stable qui s'achève en plus
sur la méthode vous vous approuver cette
méthode
hier bruno retailleau disait le tirage
au sort c'est la régression de la
démocratie mais il a raison il a raison
moi je trouve que cet outil là que je ne
veux pas accabler parce qu'il ya des
citoyens qui ont consacré du temps j'ai
toujours du respect pour ceux qui
s'engagent dans la vie publique quel que
soit leur niveau de responsabilité
je ne pense pas que le tirage au sort
soit la bonne solution c'est absurde
d'autant que je le dis le principe
républicain démocratique si celui et qui
permet aussi d'être représentés on sait
j'ai pas fait d'études j'ai pas fait de
grande école je suis pas un expert et
pour autant je représente mes
concitoyens et donc je pense que cette
mission-là de représentation elle est
noble et qu'elle fait du bien à notre
démocratie et donc je tiens à cette
démocratie représentative pour autant il
faut trouver aujourd'hui des outils de
notre temps qui permettent dans le
respect de la vème république à laquelle
nous sommes extrêmement attachés au rrq
citoyens de mieux s'exprimer
de quelle manière j'en sais rien je suis
assez favorable à cette idée selon
laquelle les citoyens puissent
directement interpellé les
parlementaires pour que des débats
s'ouvrent au parlement je pense que
c'est au parlement que c'était bas doit
se faire mais les les mais bath et j'y
suis en b2c 150 citoyens non mais ils
n'ont pas de légitimité si c'est le
tirage au sort chacun peut comprendre
que le tirage au sort c'est pas une
légitimité mais vous parlez de gadgets
ça peut aussi être un outil parfaitement
complémentaire de la démocratie
représentative
je suis pas sûr qu outil tel qu'il est
imaginé la soie soit le bon d'abord
parce qu'il peut pas durer dans le temps
puis vous savez on a beaucoup imaginé
ces outils là le conseil économique et
social et environnemental que je ne veux
pas accabler mais enfin bon on avait
imaginé très fort mais c'est ce
qu'annonce lui évitant la république
hier puisqu'il réfère en plusieurs
d'autres convention citoyenne sur
d'autres thèmes est maîtresse assez
mauvaise idée peau non mais je pense
qu'en fait la vérité la réalité c'est la
démocratie parlementaire
comment est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
que des députés des sénateurs peuvent
vraiment intervenir dans la marge
d'entre eux pays
la réalité c'est que depuis plusieurs
années emmanuel macron s'assoit sur la
démocratie parlementaire
il nous faut nous battre avec une force
considérable pour réussir à nous faire
entendre nous les représentants de la
nation ont des territoires ici au sénat
c'est là qu'il faut agir si emmanuel
macron a vraiment du courage et le
courage d'installer des contre-pouvoirs
au plus tôt des des pouvoirs
complémentaires aux siens
c'est avec les parlementaires qu'il faut
qu'ils le fassent donc là avec des
citoyens se posent entre emmanuel macron
dans cette rupture entre les français et
leurs élus mais emmanuel macron il fait
partie du système enfin pardon du ces
cette expression malheureuse mais il n'a
aucune volonté de réformer emmanuel
macron c'est un pur produit de l'élite
jones ya deux de ce pays est donc bien
là quand il n'a aucune volonté
réformatrice
c'est cette un mime il fait semblant
d'être courageux il fait semblant d'être
et formateur
sauf que le semblant maintenant ça
fonctionne plus sur le fond des
propositions il a retenu 246 des
propositions il en a rejeté trois dont
le débat le l'abaissement de la vitesse
à 110 km/heure sur les autoroutes il a
eu raison de reporter ce débat pour vous
il faut pas leur portée mais il faut
arrêter avec ce débat sur les 110 km
heure pour deux raisons la première
c'est que d'ailleurs c'est l'effet de
ces conventions citoyenne j'écoutais
hier une des animatrices qui disait vous
savez lorsque les citoyens sont rentrés
dans cette convention citoyenne
il n'était pas d'accord avec 110 km
heure et puis la fin ils ont été
d'accord et je pense que le rôle des
experts a pas été inutile pour les
rendre d'accord avec ses 110 km heure
c'est une bêtise et c'est une bêtise
parce que ça révèle bien cette vision
punitive de l'écologie à laquelle je ne
crois pas je suis profondément
écologiste
je crois profondément à la rénovation de
notre modèle de consommation notre
modèle économique pour retrouver les
grands équilibres y compris avec notre
milieu naturel mais je ne crois pas
l'écologie punitive à l'écologie des
nantis à l'écologie des beaux quartiers
et les 110 km heure
c'est l'archétype de cette écologie des
beaux quartiers pour le président la
république a également écarté une des
propositions qui consistait à demander
une taxation des dividendes à hauteur de
4%
là il a eu la bien fait où je ne veux
pas apparaître plus communiste que j'ai
tendance à l'être
de temps en temps c'est une plaisanterie
évidemment pour mes amis qui m'écoutent
nous avons dans notre pays vrai sujet
sur l'égalité fiscale peut pas le
contester
aujourd'hui il ya non adhésion à la
fiscalité dans notre pays est ce que
notre système fiscal fait le bon
équilibre entre ceux qui créent de la
valeur
ceux qui bossent qui servent tous les
matins pour aller travailler qui paie
des impôts et ceux qui utilisent une
économie fictive une économie de
spéculation
eh bien je crois pas je pense qu'on a un
travail à faire sur cette économie de
spéculation et donc je pense que tout ce
qui relève des grands flux financiers
qui aujourd'hui n'importe pas notre
économie ce que le capitalisme
historique a pu apporter
il ya quelques décennies nous devons
regarder comment leur demander un effort
supplémentaire vous auriez pris la
taxation des dividendes annonçant pas de
cette manière là parce que je pense que
c'est pas opérationnels que ça
fonctionne pas en revanche je pense
qu'il faut coder une réflexion de tous
mais c'est pas nouveau à droite et
quelques années quand nicolas sarkozy a
poussé la création du rsa le 1er rsa a
été financée avec une taxation
particulière sur certaines mouvements
financiers de l'époque c'est pas nouveau
c'est l'idée que la droite républicaine
s'est toujours faite de l'économie oui
l'économie est là pour faire grandir les
hommes mais il faut que le politique
soit capable d'orienter cette économie
ya pas de discours fou dans ce que je
dis là simplement une vision
volontariste du politique et du respect
du développement économie est clairement
là on est dans une crise économique est
ce que clairement il faut faire
contribuer plus fortement les plus
riches en l'occurrence la question des
flux financiers de la spéculation n'est
pas forcément liée à celle des plus
riches au prénom je crois pas à l'iesf
tel qu'il était conçu jusque là parce
que ça fonctionne pas ça fonctionne mal
alors non je pense en effet qu'il faut
que les plus hauts revenus est une
contribution juste ce qu'il faut c'est
retrouver de la justice dans notre pays
aujourd'hui un sentiment d'injustice qui
nous pourrit collectivement et il faut
retrouver ce chemin de la justice
ça passe aussi par la recherche d'un
meilleur modèle économique
moi je fais partie de ceux qui depuis
des mois c'est pas nouveau je n'ai pas
attendu les élections municipales pour
le dire je pense qu'il faut que nous
réfléchissions à l'évolution de notre
modèle économique
pas pour revenir à une économie
administrée évidemment on peut
interroger l'économie sans pour autant
devenir un affreux troskiste je pense
qu'il faut aujourd'hui que notre
économie soit plus orienté vers le but
de celles et ceux qui vivent sur cette
planète plutôt que vers la pure
spéculation
peut-être juste une dernière chose sur
le sur la convention citoyenne le
président a également annoncé
l'injection de 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sur deux ans notamment
dans leurs à travers le plan de relance
de l'économie
est-ce que ça c est ce que là on est sur
des montants suffisant à votre avis où
c'est aussi de l'ordre du gadget
non c'est pas du tout du gadget est le
plan de relance économique je serais le
premier à le soutenir parce que c'est
absolument vital aujourd'hui pour notre
pays
mais vous savez sur cette question
environnementale je suis extrêmement
frappé depuis depuis dimanche on dit
tout et n'importe quoi je ne pense pas
que les français adhèrent désormais à
une et de l'idéologie écologiste je
pense que le vote qui s'est portée qui
pas si massif que ça mais qui s'est
porté vers les écologistes est un vote
qui dit deux choses d'abord une envie
d'optimisme je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui que les partis politiques
dans ce pays incarne un espoir une
transformation de la société
une transformation positive de la
société je pense que c'est aussi une
volonté de renouvellement notre
démocratie
sauf que je pense que europe écologie
les verts le parti écologiste n'est pas
la bonne réponse mais nous devons être
attentifs à cet appel que les français
nous ont dansé collectivement dimanche
en disant nous voulons une nouvelle
vision de la société et il faut que nous
y apportons une réponse je peux vous
dire que la réponse de la droite
républicaine ne rappaz ne sera pas la
vision décroissante et punitive d'europe
écologie les verts mais il faut que vous
allez en parler on ne pensait pas
forcément le point fort de la droite
l'écologie et bien il faut que nous
travaillons nos points faibles
pas seulement nos points forts il ya des
sujets sur lesquels les français nous
font confiance
question régaliennes notamment question
de sécurité je pense que les français
savent qu'ils peuvent faire confiance au
sérieux à la fermeté de la droite
républicaine
mais tous les autres sujets les sujets
sociaux et sujets qui font la cohésion
sociale ce sont les sujets de demain et
je le dis électoralement la prochaine
élection présidentielle
elle se jouera sur les sujets de
cohésion sociale elle se jouera sur les
sujets d'équité de justice notamment en
matière économique elle se jouera sur
les questions de transformation de la
société
il est temps je le dis avec un peu de
naïveté peut-être mais j'essaie d'en
garder encore un peu il est temps de
retrouver un optimisme dans la vie
politique il est temps que la politique
puisse enfin plutôt à nouveau changer un
peu la vie ça fait longtemps que ça nous
et paris
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut orienter
la ligne des républicains pour vous
est-ce que ça pêche c'est le travail
quand c'est le travail que nous avons
engagées depuis plusieurs mois autour de
christian jacob nous revenons sur les
sujets de fond j'ai essayé le faire à ma
mesure travaillant sur la question des
violences conjugales il ya quelques mois
en travaillant sur les questions
d'alimentation depuis quelques semaines
avec un de mes collègues julien dive
et puis tant et tant d'autres sujets je
pense qu'il faut que la droite redit ce
qu'elle est là pour transformer la
société et qu'elle a une obsession c'est
la justice vous n'êtes citer christian
jacob qui lui voit dans les municipales
le le moment où les républicains
viennent de renouer avec la victoire
était très content du premier tour qui a
été plutôt très bon pour votre parti on
peut le dire
par contre le deuxième tour est quand
même très décevant non très décevant
vous exagérez et privés quoi mulhouse
colmar vous avez gardé en a mis en
appétit les salaires on apprit biarritz
on apprit orléans et je peux vous faire
la liste parce qu'elle est elle est
assez longue dans la vérité si je suis
certain que tu allais perdu bordeaux /
soyons factuel aujourd'hui la droite
détient près de la moitié de toutes les
communes et villes de ce pays
nous sommes majoritaires et c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce que je vous
rappelle mais nous avons des sas et là
c'est essentiellement au premier tour
oui et c'est tant mieux quand on gagne
au premier tour c'est encore mieux
gris au second tour c'est qu'on est très
fort la vérité c'est que on renoue
effectivement avec un rythme de victoire
pas fanfaronner et on sort de plusieurs
échecs cuisants présidentielle et
législatives et les européennes on monte
là il ya un déclic possible le passage
d'un seul en pointe case où nous ne
sommes pas morts et nous sommes solides
là où emmanuel macron et tant d'autres
avaient parié que nous allions mourir
la vérité c'est que c'est la république
heures marche qui était en train
d'agoniser là où nous nous sommes
solides il ya des situations dans
lesquelles nous avons des déceptions
c'est vrai pour bordeaux lisier réussi à
sauver toulouse et je salue jean avec
modem qui a fait un travail remarquable
avec son équipe
c'est une déception amoureuse ou encore
pouvoir sauver marseille c'est une
question qui se pose c'est me à 3 tours
qui sera la mer ainsi qu'une excellente
question si vous le savez je pense que
vous pouvez la dncg martine vassal des
branches et d'expression malheureux est
la solution
je pense que tout le monde discute c'est
une discussion difficile moi je regrette
que sur cette ville majeure marseille on
met ce que vous pourriez très attendue
au troisième tour un autre candidat que
martine vassal que tout est possible
aujourd'hui et je laisse les
responsables politiques marseillais mais
vous n'excluez pas à la hauteur il y
avait la volonté de la métropole de lyon
aussi en alliance avec
que faire avec la république en marche
le candidat officiel qui a été
désinvesti etc
ça n'a pas marché non plus non et c'est
une leçon pour la suite
il aurait pas pour lui faire allégeance
du tout non mais vous savez au niveau
national c'est pas nous qui avons
commandé les alliances locales se sont
fait lorsqu'elle devait saison va super
bien marché non plus regarder derrière
leur dos dont on parlait tout à l'heure
sont c'est la leçon du jour les vous
parler c'est pas qu'il ya une rupture
entre les as l'air et l'électorat urbain
non la leçon allait aller au delà ça
d'abord la première des leçons saleh de
faire alliance si nous voulons que les
français non respect qu'il faut que nous
respections nous mêmes et se respecter
soi-même c'est dire qui nous sommes
c'est moi je suis député d'une terre de
gauche j'ai été élu par des électeurs de
gauche qui savent parfaitement que c'est
un type de droite mais j'ai toujours été
clair et je pense que le respect il
commence par là donc demain il faut que
nous soyons clair il faut arrêter de
tergiverser va arrêter de tourner autour
du pot de se demander si on est
constructive bienveillant si on n'est
pas moi j'ai une opposition de fond avec
ce qu emmanuel macron est allé qui dès
qu'il a la société et je vais pas me
tortille et pour savoir si je dois être
plus aimables ou plus désagréable je dis
les choses
point barre et ça je pense que c'est la
leçon celle de la clarté c'est une leçon
politique qui d'ailleurs est une réponse
à cette espèce de de bouillie emmanuel
macron a voulu installer dans le pays
c'est d'ailleurs le principal échec
emmanuel macron les français lui ont dit
on ne veut pas de votre machin on ne
veut pas de votre truc qui est en même
temps de droite et en même temps de
gauche
on veut savoir où vous habitez et c'est
d'ailleurs une des grande noblesse de la
démocratie de savoir où on habite
y compris pour les convaincre notre
réacteur 1 jusqu'à terre général les
républicains l'ambition des républicains
s'est pas de parler seulement aux
républicains c'est de parler aux
français d'être capable demain de
convaincre l'ensemble des françaises et
des français
et commençons déjà par entrer au
gouvernement pour le faire sûrement pas
enfin pour ce qui me concerne sûrement
pas je ne rentrerai jamais dans un
gouvernement vous avez des gens sont
tentés
je n'en sais rien tous les cas si c'est
le cas je les plains les gens c'est
moralement
le journal dit jeudi que les manuels mac
on cherchera à convaincre damien abad
par exemple est-ce que damien abad
gouvernement ça serait déjà que ce soit
possible écoute et quand même une base
fondamentale dans la vie politique qui
pouvoir se regarder dans une glace
lorsqu'on se lève le matin ce qui est
pas mal
j'imagine que chacun y est attaché
d'abord par question si vous regardez le
gouvernement actuel il ya quand même pas
mal de gens qui viennent des
républicains à la base
qui visiblement ministre mais chacun se
fait l'idée qu'il se veut qu'il veut de
l'honneur en politique c'est quand même
une valeur qui peut compter encore donc
je n'imagine pas que qui que ce soit
passe ce cap là et si quelques uns ont
quelques heures le faisais je pense en
bus que ce sont des dingues pardon de
lire mais ce n'est pas au moment où le
titanic est en train de sombrer que l'on
monte dessus d'autant que sur le fond
nous avons une opposition franche avec
l'idée qu'ils emmanuel macron se fait de
la société et on ne renie pas ses
convictions pour un gyrophare sur la
voiture et en titre de ministre
la suite les élections suivantes il ya
les sénatoriales à l'automne les
départementales et régionales peut-être
l'année prochaine peut-être pas on ne
sait plus est ce que est ce que c'est
l'occasion que c'est le moment où les
républicains vont montrer que non
seulement ils sont pas morts mais ils
peuvent encore compter et se développer
oui les sénatoriales sont une étape
importante est pour vous la matière oui
ça s'annonce bien y compris parce que
gérard larcher est un excellent
président du sénat et que le travail
qu'il fait dans cette maison au sénat
est un travail de rassemblement qui fait
du bien la droite républicaine comme au
sénat les départementales et régionales
c'est peut-être un peu tôt pour le dire
mais vous allez faire mieux que sauver
les meubles ou garder vos positions vous
avez raison de dire que c'est encore tôt
pour le dire d'abord on ne sait pas
quelle sera la date je suis d'accord
avec celles et ceux qui dénoncent
aujourd'hui ce tripatouillage qui
consiste à emmanuel macron à se lever un
matin en disant mais finalement je vais
décaler la date des élections parce que
tout ça n'est pas anodin si ces systèmes
automatiques du la maladie de notre
démocratie
en démocratie à des rendez vous
électoraux on les respecte et merci
beaucoup merci aurélien fâché d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin merci stéphane
demain votre place patrick a l'air le
président du groupe socialiste
ici au sénat on passe tout de suite au
club des territoires